oder was geht ab hier ist euer maxime
herzukommen zu diesem video
warum macht ihn gar nichts von den
körper mache ich das du musst jetzt kein
körpergefühl ich sie und jetzt sind
eiskalt über alkohol blöcke
du hast du das kein einsammeln ja leute
es nimmt die change von heute keine
kohleblöcke das heißt im umkehrschluss
tranchen was das zeug hält dass ich ein
paar joints irgendwie kriegen kann und
die anderen möglichst wenige nein das
ist echt nicht gut das ist nicht gut ich
bin das nicht mehr auf platz eins gerade
im pass als foto hier hab ich würde
sagen was das zeug hält und versuch als
erste zu finden sonst wird es sehr eng
für dich die wöchentliche konzert genau
wo ich weiß du unterschied ich glaube
das erst mal 140 120 und 119 aber immer
noch ganze immer noch 360 kurs mache das
zwar nicht schlecht zusätzlich zu den
100 sich am anfang heißt du kannst am
ende maximal mit dieser charge 460 ja
gut aber man muss halt aufsehen
die karten die wir spielen sind nicht so
die op kein krieg karten sage ich mal
und weil die konzerte friedlich sind
wichtig denn kein konkret kein okay
finde ich sehr schön sechs blöcke
vorsprung passt kommen die ersten wörter
beleidigung schon rascher ja da ist mein
freund das ist die change von heute mit
100 coins an mit 104 anja jeder hasst
200 bekommen hierfür finden doch das 300
echt ja dann bekommt man vielleicht noch
200 für den ersten fisch das könnte doch
dann geht diese rechnung nämlich nicht
auf dann finden kannst du deutlich mehr
holz machen
fakt ist immer so am anfang immer bei
diesem zentralen karten herrlich
irgendwie aus wie mario und zwei jahre
auf irgendwelche ärmel oder so was
laufen kann kommt diese fucking blues
und gut aber und kannst ihn nicht übel
nehmen dass ich das immerhin der sind
teilweise des beetes autogas auch hier
guck mal das würde halt ein
das würde einfach anpassen der herald
von den leben erfüllen müsste zu diesen
körper gewöhnt sich um die kunst hat
nämlich den anflug mitgenommen hätten es
geht ja dass du jemanden vorbei fallen
unter knox das wäre jetzt der abfüllung
verhasst gewesen
das wäre ich auch eine witzige sache
dass man die größe dieser tools mutter
unter rascht und dann die besten spieler
im flug becken operativ sei positiver
junge
mein schild hätte ich keine zeit zum
chillen
das finde ich schön hier kommt können
kreativ einfordern da ist auch noch eine
typ wird jetzt was positives ist es
bringt mir nichts sei eine um alte
setzen würde ich auch wirklich auf
knappe toga das bringen wir den
resistenz der typ ist da direkt unter
mir der wird jetzt finnischen
eingefahren meinen augen obwohl
finnischen alles ist was ich habe und
gibt gas und rast geschafft weil ich mit
machst was soll ich denn machen darunter
aufnahmen trafen hier jetzt ist gutes
perfekt gibt gas und sollten kreatin
trittin kriegt die mich vielleicht auch
wirklich aufgebracht geplatzt gast gast
kann ich krieg den fischkonsum karstadt
jobs noch 1 544 ich bin unteres
mittelfeld durch dieses abgefuckte
finnischen und es ist so schwierig was
soll da sprechen die leute echt leid das
ihr euch paar das spielerlebnis
beeinflusst zu sein und mir gibt's gar
nicht geben vielmehr kunst malst du hast
kannst du einfach mal ein paar aber man
kann es schaffen
ich will einfach nach den effekten
ausschau halten ja klar natürlich erst
mal selbst spielen obwohl es ist halt
auch nicht immer gesagt das war's vorbei
täglich täglich leute aber ich werde
jetzt einfach probieren kann man es
schaffen kann man es nicht schaffen
ich bin echt blöd gestorben bisher immer
ne also es gut man kann glaube ich nicht
sehr gut teilt vorsichtig über
modenschauen oder irgendwo springt sie
trainierte ist es halt irgendwie so eine
art selbstverstümmelung wenn man gestern
marken dieses video schaut einfach die
ganzen schönen sachen nicht mitzunehmen
absolute hölle weil ich ganz finde schon
dass auf den mitnehmen möchte was meinst
du ja auf jeden fall präsent
ich kann finnischen schlagetot getätigt
ich wollte ihn nicht in ruhe lassen
ich dachte wir lassen uns vielleicht
nein nein nein ich bin jetzt 24 hat als
mann oder kann hat es gibt nämlich 400
coins okay jetzt überlege ich mal die
meisten leute werden wahrscheinlich auf
attacke gehen behaupte ich jetzt mal das
heißt ich kauf mir die bestmögliche
rüstung und setzte dann einfach darauf
dass dass er mir die guten sachen im
nachhinein irgendwie holen kann
woher die die provokative schaffen das
ist also die wahrscheinliche verschaffen
holzschwert ist nicht allzu hoch ja ich
habe 50 60 prozent oder so aber eins ja
wenn ich überhaupt man level 1
entscheidung bekomme heute ich brauche
glück ich brauch glück nach einem ja
auch immer noch zwei sein klar aber
verhält sich das sieht was sie drehte
ich war sicherlich gott leute es ist
eine harte challenge
tomtom com schon coaching stab mass
effect ja wohl auch hier sind immerhin
etwas das glück ist ja heute gesamten
runde
das glück ist die häuser wirklich es ist
echt echt schockiert ist für viele
konter sehr echt etwas bekommen muss man
sagen 'bitte nicht gar das 4 44 100
coins fast volle die rüstung bekommst
und schwert ok effekt geht in op bonmot
das natürlich eklig und es ist darum
auch den rummel auf in rom in rom in rom
erst recht vertrackt altersklasse schon
jetzt komme ich von ihnen erwartet auf
mich das ist glaube ich sein tod wurde
ja du hast vier herzen alte täglich so
viel zulassen ich glaube ich ein tor der
bogen ist richtig eklig meine muss
aufpassen ist nico koch tico abdi gucken
hoch her geht raus geht runter runter es
runter da ist nix fotografen ich bin ne
das ist ja nicht dass er nicht jeden
tanz ecoit auch obens nicken leute das
wird die aufgabe in mein kollege auf
gesamt von max wird nicht aufgenommen
mein bester freund ruft zurzeit in skype
geld ist allerding könnte ich mich ganz
heimlich rationiert schulen dann habe
ich zumindest schon mal helm das wäre
schon mal ein upgrade vielleicht noch
ein besseres schwert ein objekt
verschafft uns drauf ist apple ab heute
stellt jungen langsam ernährt sich wurde
wie geht diese wette mit der optik und
der anfang aber hinter ihm war noch nie
war ein ablauf es gibt noch drei spieler
also noch euch drei gott in der nähe
halten und er hat wahrscheinlich den op
bogen bekommen wollt dann hat auch wir
bogen glaube ich könnte immer aufhören
so viel junge komm ich muss jetzt auch
noch dazu
die association aber der einen bogen
scheint zumindest keine kriege hier die
ganze zeit die pfeile nicht wie findet
ihr das zu
aber wahrscheinlich trotzdem feier ist
völlig okay der überraschungseffekt
vielleicht einfach ja wohl die ersten
witze dir gar nicht ich glaube er legt
es tut mir leid es tut wirklich leid
über diesmal aber ich muss es der
cherokee alte change will machen junge
so lucky wichtig infiniti der das talent
findet die bau- und das bis dahin wusste
ich mache ja ich würde aber so aussehen
verpasst ok fast so der walter der platz
eins alter schwede vorleute junge das
war es unvorstellbar es war ein wink des
schicksals sind mir egal ob das war ein
wink des schicksals dass der typ genau
in diesem moment afk ist mit seiner
mutter zum essen gerufen wird
okay das war nicht ausgestattet bleibt
ja gut er will jetzt fair unbedingt
spielen
kein foto dw aber bitte fair
hey hallo es kein foto man mich nerven
diese ganzen typen diese öl kommen wir
spielen verlor bobic nein nein das spiel
ist jetzt vorbei die leute ja er will
einer feile com war jetzt einfach es ist
kein verpflichtung man kann das machen
aber nach der erfolgreichen challenge
scheinbar erfolgreichen challenge das
war alles schon gegen alle ok this town
jeans sind tut mir leid an dich kubicki
abschließen kann man sagen so wird man
ohne konflikte so vielen kleinen bakken
eine prise glück und abhaken und fehler
und macken ja leute das war's ist vom
heutigen video gibt es da hinten